welcome to this video and I'm playing
Bruce Lee and that's not good Bruce Lee
you risen from the dead playing chess
he's probably fast at the end right
prosody was very fast okay silly needs
to decide what to do here yeah g3
chatting crony and just go with my babu
go indian set up
not got a better move than Bishop g2
yeah there may be 93 as this is you can
always play and put took him some time
very important is that you pay attention
to the fact that this bishop has no
square so I'm castling actually is a
mistake due to Bishop g5 and then you
don't have a place for the bishop to go
we three as a substantial threat aha not
quite sure about all this I mean I don't
really mind him taking on before and I
don't need to take immediately its
opinion after all the the issue with
them I can I can try c5 p.m. the issue
with the porn on before is that it
hinders White's development quite
considerably the night cannot go to see
three for example yeah I wasn't sure I
could have played c5 and still um make
sure that the night is not moving but I
wasn't I wasn't sure this is a good idea
huh interesting
what if i play III 94 kind of stuff no
it's not necessary let's just play in
the center not parent doing any big
fancy moves I'm getting quite a nice
central position here maybe I have some
some chances long-term on the Kings side
with this bridge head on e4 arm really
night to be formed okay let's just
protect it it's a bit uncommon yawn
lights on before and a3 you don't see
that every game but ok why not squats
impression
yeah the light square cm the light
squares are the target and one possible
ideas naughty 62 g5 this is what I'm
trying to do see really poised putting
the night in now yeah maybe maybe with
the light squared weekend that much it's
maybe an idea my bishop could could
become a very dangerous attacking unit
but anyway i get i get stuff on the King
side here wow really check in in a
couple of seconds
isn't this like totally dangerous no
it's got basically undefended king I can
go here and take on each form it
shouldn't be bad really he cannot even
attack their three prong taking f2 and
adria that that's already gone now
cannot defend both I'm sorry you can
with that but I have 92 yeah 92 and
Queen h3 next
white resigns hmm yeah it was a really
strange strange decision now to take on
h4 I mean blacks blacks position looks
quite quite menacing but still this is
probably outwrite everything yeah a comp
is going down quickly mean- 6-7 or god
ok our it cannot take really um yeah the
whole position wasn't so easy I think
with precise play white should be a
should be okay but yeah yeah this is
this already this already is quite
dangerous he's got an offside night on a
3 this is pinned to the rook cannot
easily move and I'm getting I'm getting
near the King not not easy to play at
all quite uncomfortable in fact I think
maybe you should have kept some tension
and there is also the the thing after
age form maybe you really should play
after h5 maybe you really should play
edge form I already prefer black here
quite quite substantially there's also
the question why not here this is often
a good idea it controls some squares on
the King side but still establishes some
pressure on d5 maybe this would have
been an idea I mean what white certainty
is not not clearly were see or anything
looks a bit funky on a3 the night but it
shouldn't be a huge problem yeah I hope
you enjoyed it thanks for watching